هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره قناه
مسؤول ايراني للجزيره ان هجوم اصفهان لم
يكن ناجح وان كلام المصادر الاسرائيليه
مجرد دعايه لتعطيني على الفشل حسب تعبيره
واضاف المسؤول الايراني ان المؤشرات
الاوليه تشير الى طلوع اسرائيل في الهجوم
ولابد من متابعه تحقيقاته
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكي قال رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي ان سياسه حكومه هي منع
ايران من الحصول على سلاح النووي وهو
الموقف نفسه الذي اكد عليه وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
هذا وصفت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه الهجوم
على مصنع العسكريين في ايران بالاستفزازيه
نقلت رولترز عن الخارجيه الروسيه قولها
انها مثل هذه التصرفات المدمره قد تكون
لها تبعات غير متوقعه على السلام
والاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط
في تونس قال رئيس الهيئه العليا المستقله
للانتخابات فاروق معسكر ان نسبه لاختراع
العامه في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
التشريعيه بلغت 11 وثلاثه اجزاء في المئه
حسب نتائج الاوليه وفي اثناء دعى رئيس
جبهه الخلاص الوطني احمد نجيب الشاذلي الى
رحيل الرئيس السعيد وتنظيم الانتخابات
الرئاسيه مبكرا تكون خطوه الاولى لمسار
الاصلاحيه كامل
وقال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد نسبه
الاقبال على الانتخابات الاخيره يجب ان
تقرا بشكل مختلف حيث لم يشارك 90 في المئه
في التصويت لان البرلمان لم يعد يعني لهم
شيئانا ولم تعد لهم ثقه فيه
ولا رئيس الامريكي
اجابته على سؤال لاحد الصحفيين اما اذا
كانت واشنطن ستزودك بالمقاتلات حيث جاءت
اجابته
اما الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون فقال ان
بلاده لم تتلقى طلبا من كيف بتسليمها
طائرات مقاتله واكد ماكرون خلال مؤتمر
صحفيا مع رئيس الوزراء الهولندي ماركروت
انه في حال طلبه اوكرانيا ذلك فان فرنسا
لا تستبعد القيامه باي شيء لدعمها ولكن
وفق شروط
كما قال رئيس الوزراء البولندي
اي قرار بارسال طائرات اف 16 الى اوكرانيا
سيتم بتنسيق كامل مع دول واضاف انه تتبعوا
جميع خطواته تقويه القدرات الدفاعيه في
اوكرانيا مع شركائها في الحلفه وبشكل خاص
مع واشنطن
[موسيقى]